[Music]
how's it going or everybody's Lord
watching here from hordes of gaming
dotnet I'm here with Forrest here we're
gonna talk about Drake Hollow and so
tell us about the key so it is a we're
calling it a survival action village
builder basically you solo or with
friends find yourself sucked into this
world called the hollow that's populated
by Drake's which are essentially
adorable little vegetable goblins and
your job is to build villages for them
and protect them
awesome awesome so to make a little bit
of gameplay that we have shown off on
here so what's going down with the
player so he's just right at the
beginning of the demo he's dropped into
this island and surrounded by this ether
which is this sort of deadly miasma that
covers the world but he's just picked up
a ward and he can use that to traverse
the ether this is a thing you craft so
you build waste essentially to get
around and initially it's just things
like this that make a little bubble
around you you can also build networks
that you rail grind that carry supplies
to your camp from supply depots out in
the world that you discover perfect
looks like he's expending two creativity
for the player so talk a little bit
about what players can find and they can
craft in the world of drink Hollow well
a lot of what we call curios they're
basically like gadgets that do things
like protects you from the ether or
serve as decoys from an enemy's attack
or rocks mines like all sorts of just
combat gameplay oriented things jump
pads basically we call that a teleport
or what is it a translocator but the a
lot of the building and crafting is
around building the village itself which
starts out with so you rescue a Drake
and they have needs like they need food
they need water they need entertainment
they can die of boredom and they need a
place to sleep so you're building stuff
to address those needs so like so the
first thing you're building are like
poppets to keep them happy but they
don't last very long
all right so like the next level thing
is the yoga ball which they could play
with it makes them happy
you're building like planters the beds
and eventually defenses as well so you
can build higher and higher level fences
to protect your camp from attack and
even like bunkers and traps and whatnot
to take out enemies what they do start
attacking your camp right so right now
he's still in the very intro part of the
demo which is basically that get around
the world part of the game he's talking
to wise crow who's like your guide early
on in the game who's telling him
essentially how to connect up a rail
network so we're gonna see in a moment
once he's done reading this he's going
to go connect that the the ether relay
to the camp and he's going to be able to
glide right over the ether I you know
there he goes he found it and eventually
like I said you can you can traverse
these see him connected up and then also
oh maybe we won't see him connected up
let's say he's concentrating his he's
getting there he's getting there it's in
there he's done it now when he
disconnects he will be able to ride that
beam and get to the camp it was like
it's definitely a hearing to
accessibility when you're traveling it
makes it easier for you to craft and
gather materials yeah yeah exactly the
more I mean you you need to gather
supplies they get consumed as you build
these things but you can build a bigger
and bigger network that crosses all the
different islands in the region
perfect perfect well the game is looking
great is super polished and art styles
fantastic so tell us when players able
to get their hands on the game so we're
coming out in q2 of this year and we're
coming to Windows 10 and Xbox via game
Pass perfect perfect thank you so much
for your time for this great song to you
good luck are you developed for trade
Kyle oh there's one more question how
many of you were actually working on
this game right now the team is 11
perfect okay cool thank you so much for
your time is Lorin Maazel milords gaming
net do you guys so much for watching
[Music]